Is, I do know your blood type [inaudible] Oh,
I think. Is that good? Well, I mean, I know there's three different times,
right? There's O a, B and AB. Yeah. Yeah. The Brown one, right.
AB is the right one.
Yeah. I mean, I should know because I have like a blood disease,
so I used to have a medical bracelet. You probably should know too.
Then you have a medical bracelet. Uh, that would be like, you know, if I,
if I am bleeding, please give me this thing specifically.
And then I know what your parents are. Uh, no, but then I lost that.
I lost the medical bracelet, so I don't know where it is. So, uh,
you probably shouldn't learn science. I haven't got a replacement.
It's been like a few years now. Sorry.
Mental, like have where that always.
Meant to, it's just like a suggestion from the docs.
What blows my mind? What blows my mind though, is that in Japan?
At least like in Japanese schools, like you can get bullied for your blood type.
man. That's next level bullying. It's like, it's like, Oh, you're an,
a type racism with extra steps.
Yeah. That does sound like a, an excuse. It's like, I think he's a filthy odor.
Yeah. You kind of hang out with us Oh times, because you're an, a type. Right.
And like, because why does everyone know each other's blood type? Yeah.
I think, I think it's because like, when you do like a health checks,
we did that. Yeah. I haven't done mine yet.
It shouldn't be written on your show. So to explain,
since we're signed with geeks,
plus we are technically under their health insurance and their company policy is
that we have to get a health checkup once a year.
Which everyone in Japan has to do is watch everyone in Japan.
Twice a year. Okay. We've been here for one year already mailing,
but we've already had one checkup. How does that work? Okay.
So we're supposed to go twice, just been once. Um,
and it was weird because I,
it was weird seeing how efficient a health system can be.
Cause I haven't, I haven't gone yet. It took about 20 minutes. He was like,
okay, well still that's it.
In 30 minutes, I, you do an x-ray, uh, your blood pressure,
you get weighed or you get blood taken. Uh, you do a hearing and, uh,
psych tests, you talk to a doctor, he'll talk to you.
And then you do a cardiogram and a cardiogram. Wow. 20 minutes.
All in 30 minutes, it was like, it was like speed running. We, we,
we were speed running health checks. And they even had like Smiths as well.
[inaudible] x-ray split, done blood taking split. Let's go.
It literally felt like that. Cause it was like, cause I was about like, uh,
because I had some problems with my forms. I had to fill out my form again.
So I was only about like five to 10 minutes behind Connor.
And by the time I had just like, just started my like I'm to call it,
I'm going to call it a conveyor belt. Cause that's what it felt like.
It felt like I was in chicken run, being processed. Um, so I was,
I had just started the process and kinda was almost done.
It was the most efficient because I saw the list of all the things that get
checked off. And I was like, Oh, this is going to be like an older.
Yeah. You also have to pee the night before and bring it with you,
which I just always feel
[inaudible] what about my.
Derives? So you go into this room.
It's like this really busy place in like Shinju,
which I imagine a lot of people will go to Japan and then there's like,
you go to this reception area. There's like 12 desks, like, all right,
come here. You hand the form though. Right? Go upstairs. You go upstairs. Yeah.
Everyone's in like medical downs or whatever, really fancy office looking thing.
It's really odd. And it's basically just a small room.
Not even that big with like couches in the middle.
And then you can see the like section, like it's a food court of like,
what's going to do what? You can see everyone getting blood taken.
You can see everyone, you.
See everyone doing everything. And then.
They're like, all right, go in this room, get changed.
So you put the medical counter, you come back in and then right.
You have a number. So you have literally like a, a chicken and a font.
It's like actually chicken diet is literally like.
Piece of meat being passed around the different things. You gotta get sanitized.
And so you just, they basically just come in,
they're like number 124 and then you go in.
And then you just have to like,
hopefully understand what they're saying in Japanese. They tell you, Oh yeah,
it was just fast. It was like, boom, boom, boom. Wow. But I was like, dude.
I hate blood tests. I hate getting my blood test. Yeah. God,
I haven't done that in a while. And then I was like, I was just.
Yeah, yeah. I got to do my next week. Yeah.
That's fun. It's fun. Isn't it?
It's not it's as fun as a health check can be because I,
it was something that was so alien for me, especially coming from the UK,
which you know, big RPNs NHS for giving, giving everyone,
everyone free healthcare. But the price you pay for that is that you have to.
Wait for every yeah, yeah. Yeah.
When I say everything, even just going to the GP it's sometimes,
sometimes you're like, you got a fever or something. I've phoned up my GP.
And they're like, Oh we can't six days. Yeah. We can't,
we can't book you in until next week. And I'm just like, great.
I guess I'll just try to sleep off this
week then I'm by the time you can see the GP you've already most of the time
you've you've already recovered. Yeah.
Yeah. I think I never see the doctor in London,
but I booked three times to see it when I was like dying.
And every time before the appointment,
I got better and I had to cancel it because it was like, I'm already better.
Right. It literally takes a week. At least in London it's even, it's worse.
But I remember like, I would like, I think I fall,
I broke my arm one time when I was a kid and I was,
I was in the emergency room and I'm like, dude, I'm gonna have to get an x-ray.
And they're like, yeah. So, uh,
come back in a week and a half and we'll give you an x-ray. And I'm like, what?
Like, what am I supposed to do in a week? What about my arm?
Let's come back in a week and a half. And I'm like,
but what I do tell them like, Oh, just don't do anything to it. I'm like,
don't do anything to it. I want to do for a week and a half. Not move my arm.
But he was so stupid, man.
And it was so weird going to the Japanese health checkup. And they like,
they started off with the x-ray. Cause like, when I think x-ray,
I'm just like in my head, I'm just like,
I'm not getting an x-ray and unless it's something serious.
So this is obviously like the big checkup. This is the x-ray but no,
they looped us up. Looped us up with a x-ray man.
Like we went in there and then we just like, they they'd go,
please go to the x-ray machine.
Uh, uh, rectangle on a wall and you just put your chest against it. Yeah.
Really.
Odd. Because when I x-ray, I imagined like the.
[Inaudible] it was bizarre.
I've never, I've never had an x-ray done before.
So it was weird actually was the cardiogram, which a way where you, like,
I've never had that before. I've never had that before,
where it's like lie down on the bed and you kind of feel like a mental patient
about to get lobotomized. Cause they put these suckers on you.
They put these socks on you and then they put these appendages on your, uh,
on your heart and your arms and legs. And yeah,
it just kind of feels like you're about to get on the bottom.
I was waiting for like the electric shock to go hit me.
But there nothing happened to me that they like they to loop me up as well.
They just put like lube on you. Cause I think I had chest hat.
It doesn't go with what me? What do you mean? It's it's a natural.
Mail is a mailing is a,
I'm not talking about my in-depth colonoscopy may or may of mailings off screen.
Just like blushing.
Which by the way, the smallest detail I was told, if you're over 35 every year,
you have to have a colonoscopy. Really? Yeah. Every year you have to call off.
It's because of it's because uh, Japan in Japan,
hemorrhoids is a really common problem. I'm I'm legit. I'm legit serious.
Like I think it's, I think I saw something like crazy.
Like one in four men in Japan have hemorrhoids. Yeah.
Connor was telling me afterwards that he doesn't want to call it an OCP because
he's afraid that it'll awaken.
[Inaudible] if I dig it, man, what are you going to like crack a fat on the
[inaudible]. Cause I was, I was momentarily confused as a cold be on my weight
. I'm like, which end is that? Cause.
What about it? Would you rather something go up your or down your throat? My.
I thought he thought he was going down your throat.
So they check your throat or down like, what's that called?
That's a different thing. Right.
And I was like, I was like, totally down. I'm like, all right, fine.
Put it in my.
Down my throat, whatever up my.
No, no, no. It's the opposite.
Something on my man down my throat.
[Inaudible] what would you then also,
when we would do this health checkup as well, they would like,
we had like the blood pressure thing and like the thing in it,
which also always feels squeezes your arm. And then the doctor was like, yeah,
you did. You did good on that. And I'm like, what does that mean?
What does that mean? What is doing bad?
I'm like explain what did good means that your numbers are good? I'm like, yeah,
explain the numbers to me. What is this supposed to mean? I got, there was like,
I.
Put all my attention into my arm to change my blood pressure.
I wasn't, I was doing something like hunt to hunt and then on that thing.
I'm like heart rate, zero.
Avatar, blood bending. It's just like.
I will now make my heart rate zero. So my enemies cannot find me.
And we got our blood taken and I remember we would talk before we got a blood
test. We were talking about, you know,
we were talking about how the Japanese health system that we've had.
We've all had pretty good experiences with the Japanese health system because we
will have like, I don't know why we will have like that inherent fear that,
you know, everyone's had a,
experience Winnie have taken the blood and they've just missed the vein. Right.
That happened to me.
That's really, yeah.
For shadowing, that happened to me.
Cause I knew it as soon as he stuck the needle in. Cause you know, you,
you can feel it when, when like it goes straight to your vein. Yeah.
It feels exactly like the doctor describes it's just like a prick. Right.
And it just comes out.
So he sticks this needle in and I could feel immediately that something was
wrong. Cause he was like,
that's not a vein that's muscle and you start feeling pain.
And I felt sorry for anyone who has like a needle phobia. Cause I'm gonna,
I'm not like, so I can feel him like kind of twitching the needle around.
I'm just like, how do I tell him it's not there?
How do I tell them this or that?
And he does it for like a full like minute before he realizes,
Oh there's no blood coming out. And I look and I look pulling up fat.
I look over and there's like, you know, you know, like the vial of blood,
there's like the volume, the volume was filled up that much. Like the man,
he was poking my arm and I'm like, like scar tissue, done, man. I knew it.
So.
Oh gosh, embarrassed. I was like, I want to be cool. And not like, like myself.
Yeah. But then I was like, Oh God. And I was like, Oh no, the nurse is cute.
Oh no, I can't. I'm going to.
Needles.
I feel needles are the only time where you can bring out your inner and just be
like, I don't, I don't, I can't look at the needle going in. I like,
Oh I have to look at the needle. Yeah. I like, it's on the contrary for me.
If I, if he's like, all right, we're going to go in.
And if I don't see it and I feel a prick that scares me, he's just like,
he's like, it's going in. Yeah.
[Inaudible]. What about, what about staring at you being like pierced helps you?
Because I know when the pain is coming.
You know what I mean?
Then you're expecting the pain.
That's worse for me is unexpected pain where I'm just like.
Feel it if you don't look there. No, no, no. I feel it more if I don't.
Yeah, because that's, that's like, have you, have you ever like cut yourself?
I'll have like an injury. You don't feel it all day.
And then suddenly you look at it and you're like, wow, there's a cut.
And then suddenly you start feeling it that's me. That's me and needles. Really?
Because every time I get cut, it's just like, I can't be a pain.
Like I can't imagine seeing blood literally gush out of my veins and thinking,
yeah, that's a, that looks like dirt. Like during the summer, for instance,
like, cause like during the summer, your blood pressure is a lot higher.
So when the blood comes out, it kind of just like gushes out and I'm just like,
Oh, that looks sick. I like looking at that. It's kind of cool. I missed.
Coming out of my body. It was a kid.
They would just give me this like contraption that was just like filled with
like paint oil. And it were just like,
all of it would like you would flip it over and it stopped playing like crazy.
We should do that to distract because I was like, wow, look at that thing guys.
The Bible I'm like, Whoa, that's cool. That's weird. I can't do that. Really.
I was just like, I put my hand on the table. I'm like, go ahead.
You smacked it all. I.
Was like, I was like, cool. I was like, Kaline there, go ahead.
Why'd you have to like smack it. I'm like, come on,
get ready boy belt in the mouth. I'm not using mine.
We're using mine was with me because,
because normally when I get my blood taken, I'm used to it being like a,
like a private place. You know what I mean?
So we get our blood takens, like a conveyor belt. And I was just like,
I hang up the next guy. I think the guy next to me,
he's taken three of us right here getting our blood take. It was very odd.
And neither of us could look at the,
look at the blood getting taken and we just like met eyes and just like,
it's like me to guys in a urinal. It's like, this is awkward.
How's your day going? Oh, that's that's uh,
that's you look like an old type there. I forgot
what I was trying to strike up. Any conversation.
It is odd that we kind of made it into a private thing in the West. Right?
Like does it breathing to be private getting your blood taken?
I mean, it doesn't, but I would, I feel,
I think it's that people would prefer it. Right.
But if, if, if that means that, you know,
I get medical tests way quicker in the UK,
by all means do my colonoscopy in front of the other patients. I do not mind.
Like, let's get this.
It's like, Oh, you crack the fat too.
Does that means I can get it done 20% faster?
And I can get on with my day gladly. I'll I'll I'll get it. I'll get my blood.
If I fail in front of a group of 20 people who cast.
In my head, I was like, Oh, this is going to be an all day thing.
I got a health chicken anywhere else. All day.
Yeah. Yeah. Well,
I think the worst part was that you couldn't eat or drink anything the night
before, after 8:00 PM, you have to stop eating and drinking.
And normally that wouldn't be a problem.
But when you tell me I can't eat and drink, I'm like, well. Now I want to.
Well, now I want to just drink water or you can drink the NICU.
I was going to say, I drink, but water is the only thing.
Drink alcohol. I was like British people like shaking.
Yeah. Basically no substance, like in your bloodstream,
the nicest substance. What are you? What are you taking? God. God's like,
you got to put the belt and spoon away.
They're going to see my heroin veins and everything, man.
So hit the heroin vain. Don't don't worry. I got this. I've done this before.
I'm kidding. This is a joke. How does Karen again, you take a pint of heroin.
It's a pain. It's a pain.
Can't believe the trash tastes. Boys might like it,
but in the light of drug addicts, hounded. Wow.
In case you don't get sarcasm, none of us have done heroin
yet. I'm less.
That's the dark arc of the trash.
Trailer. Trash taste. Oh my God.